Voiceover: What I want to
do in this video is try
to give a reasonable understanding
of the different players
involved that issue and process
your credit cards.
Let's start off with the processors.
Sometimes you could say that the network,
or the processors are
the people that maintain
the credit card networks.
Examples of those are Visa, Mastercard,
American Express, Discover.
What they do is they,
essentially, maintain networks
of IT and policies that connect
a bunch of banks together.
For just the sake of this
video, we'll do very simple.
Let's say that this is
network 1, maybe that's Visa.
Maybe this right here is network 2.
This right here could be Mastercard.
Right now the networks are
just circles, but you'll see
that they're networks as I
build out this explanation.
Let's say that I'm some bank out there.
Let me call myself bank A.
I decide that, you know
what, it would be good
for my business for me
to issue a credit card.
I could extend credit to my customers,
they'll pay me interest,
maybe I'll make some fees
off of that, and it'll be
good business for my bank.
I go up to Visa and I say,
"Hey, can I be a member
"of your network?"
Visa has some policies and
if you're a legitimate bank
and you agree to all those policies,
you'll become a member of that network.
I've joined the network
and I'm, of course,
not the only person on that network.
There's tons of other
banks on that network.
That could be bank B,
this could be bank C,
this could be bank D.
Of course, each of these are
networks, so they all have
their own member banks on them.
That's Mastercard's network right there.
In this situation, let's say
I'm a customer of bank A.
They say, "You want a credit
card?" and I say, "Sure.
"That'll be convenient, I
don't like carrying cash
"in my pocket, so give me a credit card."
They'll issue a credit card
that looks something like this.
The credit card, I think
we've all seen credit cards,
It'll say Bank A really big up at the top.
Bank A, I'll have a credit
card number that's unique
to me, my credit card number,
my name will be there,
some type of expiration
date, and then here
in the bottom right corner,
they're going to say
what network I'm a part of.
In this case, it would be Visa.
A credit card issued over
here would say Mastercard
or if it was American Express, they'd put
American Express here, or
maybe there's some type
of a hologram.
Great, I have a credit card here.
I think we all have a general sense.
I could use it and then
I'll build a balance
and then in the future I
could pay off that balance
to this bank or I could carry a balance
and they'll charge me
interest, which is usually
reasonably high interest,
so I want to pay it off
fairly quickly, but how
does this actually work
in the context of a network?
Let's say I go to the local grocery store.
Let me draw that in orange.
Let's say I go to some
grocery store over here.
I'll say G for grocery.
I buy $100 worth of
groceries and I want to pay
with my newly issued credit card.
Let me write this down.
This is the issuing, issuer.
This is the issuing bank.
I go to the grocery store,
I say, "Hey, I'd like to pay
"with a credit card."
The grocery store, if
they accept credit cards,
they need to have some
relationship with another bank
someplace on this Visa
network, in order for them
to accept a Visa card.
Let's say that they have
a relationship with bank B
over here.
This would be the merchant
bank, or we could say
the retailer's bank, or it's
often in credit card lingo called
the acquiring bank or the acquirer.
You might wonder why is
it called the acquirer?
It's called the acquirer
because this is the player
that goes out and goes
to each of the merchants
and says, "Hey, right
now you only accept cash
"or you only accept American Express.
"Wouldn't it be great if
you also accepted Visa
"or Mastercard?
"That way you'll have more
appeal to more customers
"and it'll be more
convenient for your customers
"and every time a transaction
happens, we'll just take
"a little bit of a cut
of that transaction."
So they go out and acquire
different retailers.
This was the grocer, maybe bank B goes off
and acquires the shoemaker, maybe he goes
and he gets the tailor on the network.
These are all different
retailers who will now,
all of a sudden, accept Visa,
because their merchant bank is a member
of the Visa network.
Likewise, it could've been a member
of the Mastercard network,
it doesn't matter.
This is the processor and
this is their network.
Now, this guy, in this
context, he would accept Visa.
I would give him my Visa
card and the first process
is called authorization.
That's literally to check
whether I'm good for the money,
whether this card is
valid to buy $100 worth
of groceries.
When I swipe the card or
when the grocer swipes
the card, it's going to send a message
from that little unit, from
the point of sale unit,
to the acquiring bank.
That's going to be forwarded to Visa.
Then Visa will say, "Oh,
that's bank A's card,"
and they'll give a number to bank A
on their own proprietary network.
Then bank A will look into
their database and say,
"Oh yeah, Sal's got $1,000
of credit, he hasn't used
"any of it, he is good for it.
"I authorize the transaction."
That message goes back through the network
to bank B, so then we get authorized.
Then the transaction goes
forward and eventually,
as you could imagine,
you can't just authorize
a transaction and then I
walk away with the groceries.
At some point, this guy here expects
to get his money back for
giving me the groceries.
He expects to get $100 back.
That $100 is going to come from bank A,
but he's not going to get a complete $100,
because obviously, each of these players,
they're providing a service.
This guy, he's plugged into the network
and he's offering credit.
The network operator or
the processor is offering
their network and there's other services
they might provide, different
security mechanisms.
They say, "Sal lives in
Chicago, but all of a sudden,
"he's buying $100 worth
of groceries in Salzburg
"or someplace that seems unlikely."
Then it might send some
type of a warning trigger,
so people might have their
own security mechanisms.
They're all providing a service.
This guy is going out
there, he might be providing
the actual point of sale
terminals, the actual network,
so they're all going to get a
little bit of a cut of things.
Out of the $100, I got
$100 worth of groceries.
There'll be a 2%, and it's not always 2%,
that's a round number,
but it also is a ballpark,
not completely outlandish,
relative to what tends
to be the case.
Of that $100 that this guy could've gotten
for his groceries, he has to pay a 2% ...
Yeah, let's write it that way.
He's got to pay a 2%, or in this case $2,
that's 2% of $100.
He's got to pay a $2 discount
rate to his acquiring bank.
You might say, "Gee, the
acquirer, that's great.
"They get 2% of all of
these guys' transactions,"
but of course they're
going to have to share it
with these other people up here.
Actually, the bulk of
it ends up with bank A.
Of this $2, and I'm doing
it in roundabout numbers,
bank A, now we're going
to split up the $2,
bank A is going to get,
let's just say, $1.70.
These aren't that far off
from what the real numbers
might be and they change
and they depend on the banks
and the network and all of that.
The networks might change their rates.
$1.70 goes to bank A.
The issuing bank, besides now that I have
a credit balance, it'll be
able to charge interest on it.
It also got $1.70 for that transaction.
That $1.70 of the $2, this
is called an interchange fee.
This right here is an interchange fee.
It generally gets set by
the individual networks.
Although, the networks don't
share that interchange fee.
They just say, "Our standard
interchange fee is X%
"of transactions plus $0.10,"
and that's what bank B
is going to pay to bank A.
It's essentially bank A's
cut of the discount rate,
of the $2 this guy is charging that guy.
Then, the network, they make their money
in several ways, but in
general, they make money
off of every transaction, as well.
In this situation, they
make roughly about 1000th
of the transaction or .1%
In this example, $0.10
of this discount rate
that this guy charged
would go to the processor
or the network.
Every time you transact,
the processor gets
a small fraction of your actual purchase.
Then, this guy will be left with 30 -
Well, let's see.
$1.70, $0.10, $1.80.
We're coming from $2, this
guy's going to be left
with $0.20.
When the whole transaction gets settled,
which essentially means
everyone gets the money
they need to get, this bank
is going to send Visa's
settlement bank $100 minus the $1.70
that it gets to keep as
part of its interchange fee.
It's going to send Visa, what is that,
that's $98.30 to Visa.
Visa will keep $0.10 of it,
send it to the acquirer,
so the acquirer is going to get $98.20.
Then the acquirer is going
to keep $0.20 for itself
and give the retailer $98.
My numbers aren't exact,
but I want to give you
the general idea of how all this works.
In order for this retailer
to be able to use all
of this infrastructure out
there, he essentially had to pay
2% of the actual transaction.
That's always not going
to be 2%, but it gives you
a nice, round figure.
This guy benefits because
he gets access to a network,
it's convenient for the customers.
This guy, obviously, is
getting some type of fee.
The more retailers he signs
on, or the more retailers
he acquires, the more cuts of transactions
he's going to make.
Visa makes a small cut on
many, many transactions,
so that's where they make their money.
They obviously have to
use some of that money
to support all of this infrastructure.
Then bank A is going to
make that interchange fee,
which was the bulk of that discount rate,
that retailer discount
rate, not related at all
to the federal funds discount rate.
Then, of course, they
extended credit to me,
so that $100 might not
be paid immediately.
They might be able to charge me 15-20%
annualized percentage rate
interest on that money
until I pay it off.
Of course I have some
type of minimum balances
to pay.
Hopefully that explains
things a little bit.
I'll see you in the next video.